Вітаю на уроці 7-го класу алгебри.
Мене звати Владислав Кононенко.
Тема сьогоднішнього уроку:
лінійні рівняння з двома
змінними та їх розв`язання.
Перейдемо до першого питання.
А що взагалі таке
рівняння з двома змінними?
Розглянемо декілька випадків,
які нам дуже добре відомі.
Деякі взяті з геометрії, а
деякі з реального життя.
Тож перший приклад
Маємо прямокутник з відомою площею.
Площа даного прямокутника
буде 12 см квадратних.
Позначимо за його виміри як а та
b, відповідно довжина та ширина.
Знаючи формулу площі, отримаємо
відповідне рівняння a помножене на b
отримаємо 12 – це і буде рівняння з двома
змінними (в якості змінних буде а та b).
Другий варіант.
Ми маємо шість зошитів та дві лінійки.
Якщо позначити вартість одного зошита
за x та вартість однієї лінійки за у –
ми можемо скласти такого
виду рівняння: 6х+2у=18.
Це також є рівнянням з двома змінними
(в якості змінних виступатимуть х та у).
І останній випадок
це всім відома властивість:
сума гострих кутів прямокутного
трикутника дорівнює 90 градусів.
Якщо позначити гострі
кути як альфа та бета –
отримаємо альфа плюс бета дорівнює 90.
Що ж таке розв`язок?
Власне – рівняння з двома змінними.
Що означає розв`язати це рівняння?
Давайте ми це з вами визначимо.
Пару значень змінних, яка перетворює
рівняння в правильну рівність,
називають розв`язком
рівняння з двома змінними.
Дивимось на екран.
Отже, якщо ми маємо деякі два числа, які
підставляючи замість х та у відповідно,
отримаємо правильну рівність,
тобто 0 дорівнює 0, чи 5 дорівнює 5 –
це означає, що ця пара чисел
була розв`язком нашого рівняння.
І давайте розглянемо
добре відомі нам випадки.
Знайдемо деякі розв`язки цих рівнянь.
Дивимось на екран.
Перше. Якщо замість а підставити 3.
Може довжина прямокутника дорівнювати 3?
Так. То тоді якою має бути ширина,
щоб площа нашого
прямокутника дорівнювала 12?
Єдиний варіант який
підходить – це буде 4.
Тому пара чисел 3 і 4 буде розв`язком
даного рівняння з двома змінними.
Але це не означає, що він єдиний.
Це не зовсім звичні рівняння,
як ви звикли з 6 класу,
де є рівняння і воно має
зазвичай єдиний розв`язок.
Це рівняння має безліч розв`язків.
Наприклад, можна підставити 1
та 12 чи поміняти місцями 12 та 1.
Можемо побачити приклади
розв`язків даного рівняння
і так само проробити для випадку 2 та 3.
Отримаємо деякі варіанти розв`язків
цих рівнянь. Дивимось на екран.
Перейдемо до певних прикладів
Приклад 1.
Умова на дошці.
Умова на дошці.
Оскільки точка А, точніше її координати,
є розв`язками даного рівняння –
це означає, що підставляючи
їх під відповідні зміни,
ми отримаємо правильну рівність:
3 відповідатиме змінній х,
а с відповідатиме змінній у.
Зробимо підстановку.
Отримаємо рівняння
такого вигляду: 2*3 – 5*с = 1.
2 помножити на 3 – отримаємо 6 і
переносимо його в праву частину.
В правій частині ми отримаємо
вираз 1-6, тобто мінус 5.
І дане рівняння перетвориться на
тотожне йому рівняння, тобто -5с = -5
Звідси отримаємо відповідь, що с = 1.
Розглянемо інший приклад.
Потрібно визначити
кількість розв`язків рівнянь.
Вам могло здатися, що у рівнянь з
двома змінними завжди безліч розв`язків.
Це не так. Ми продемонструємо
Вам це на прикладах.
Тож перший приклад.
Умова на дошці, приклад 1
Скільки розв`язків матиме це рівняння?
Вам відомо, що квадрат
не може бути від`ємним –
він завжди більший або рівний за нуль.
І цей вираз – сума двох доданків,
який написаний в лівій частині,
а в правій частині у вас нуль.
То як сума квадратів двох доданків,
які обидва не можуть бути від`ємними,
може дорівнювати нулю?
Тільки в єдиному випадку,
коли кожен з них дорівнює нулю.
Це буде єдиним
розв`язком даного рівняння,
коли х=0 та у=3 для того, щоб
другий доданок теж дорівнював нулю.
Один розв’язок.
Випадок номер два.
умова на дошці, приклад 2
Вираз у лівій частині рівняння
має на один доданок більше.
І якщо про перші два доданки
ми можемо сказати те саме,
що і про два доданки в першому
випадку, то третій доданок –
він не просто не може бути
від`ємним, він більший за нуль,
він дорівнює 1
тому сума трьох чисел
(два з яких не можуть бути від`ємними
або ж більше або рівне за 0 і 1)
воно завжди буде більше строго за 0.
Тому друге рівняння не має розв`язку.
Випадок № 3.
Умова на дошці.
Добуток двох виразів дорівнює нулю.
Де х квадрат + y квадрат – це перший
вираз, y – другий вираз.
Ви знаєте що добуток дорівнює нулю,
якщо одне з них дорівнює 0 – або
перший вираз, або другий вираз.
Якщо перший вираз - х квадрат
плюс у квадрат дорівнює 0,
повертаємось до випадку №1,
він має всього єдиний розв`язок,
коли і х, і у дорівнюють 0, і
може скластись враження,
що у третього рівняння
всього один розв`язок,
ми вже розглянули цей
випадок і він дорівнює 0.
Але це не так.
Розглянемо другий – коли у=0,
а про х нічого не сказано.
Це означає, що він може бути будь-яким.
Друга частина цього рівняння
має відповідь у=0, а х – будь-який.
Оскільки х будь-який –
це означає, що їх безліч.
Тобто точка (1;0) вона нам підходить.
Давайте це перевіримо: (1 + 0) х 0 = 0.
Дійсно.
Отже безліч розв`язків.
Переходимо далі.
Четверте рівняння.
Стандартне рівняння з двома
змінними і воно має теж безліч розв`язків,
ми можемо просто продемонструвати
це на декількох прикладах.
Наприклад, замість х і у
можна підставити 1 і 1, або 2 та 0,
чи можна підставити певні
дроби, наприклад 1/5 додати 0,5,
чи від`ємні числа -3 та 1.
Я думаю цього достатньо,
щоб зробити висновок,
що четверте рівняння
має безліч розв’язків.
Серед всіх цих рівнянь варто
виокремити певний вид рівнянь.
Називатиметься він лінійні
рівняння з двома змінними.
Що ж таке лінійне
рівняння з двома змінними?
Лінійним рівнянням з двома
змінними називається рівняння,
яке має такий вигляд:
ах + bу = с, де ху відповідають
за змінні цього рівняння;
а – називають коефіцієнтом перед х;
b – називають коефіцієнтом перед у;
с – називають вільний член.
Повертаємось до знайомих нам задач.
Скажіть мені, будь ласка, які з
цих рівнянь будуть лінійними?
Давайте розбиратись.
Перше рівняння не є лінійним, оскільки
загальна степінь цього виразу дорівнює 2
(у нас перша змінна у першій степені
та друга змінна у першій степені).
А в загальному вигляді
лінійного рівняння,
тобто ах + bу = с степінь кожного
виразу дорівнює максимум 1,
оскільки а, b і с константи.
Тож перше рівняння не є лінійним.
Натомість друге рівняння 6х + 2у = 18
повністю відповідає
вигляду лінійного рівняння,
де коефіцієнт перед х буде
6; коефіцієнт перед у буде 2;
18 буде відповідати за вільний
член; х, у – відповідні змінні.
Аналогічно можна
стверджувати і про третє рівняння.
Коефіцієнти перед змінними у нас будуть
дорівнювати 1 та 1,
та вільний член буде 90.
Пропоную дати вам відповідь
на таке моє запитання.
Запитання та варіанти відповідей
на нього ви бачите на екрані.
Правильний варіант – воно
буде лінійним рівнянням.
Більш того рівнянням з двома змінними
просто перед змінною у коефіцієнт буде 0.
Якщо ми знову згадаємо рівняння х = 2,
то до нього можна дописати
в лівій частині х + 0у = 2
і тоді коефіцієнти будуть перед х –
1, перед у – 0 та вільний член буде 2
– воно повністю відповідає вигляду
лінійного рівняння з двома змінними.
Продемонструємо ще декілька прикладів
лінійних рівнянь. Умови на дошці.
Перше рівняння майже
нічим не відрізняється
від лінійного рівняння загального
вигляду з двома змінними,
єдине що перетасовані змінні місцями.
У загальний вигляд воно
перетворюється завдяки тому,
що х ми переносимо в
ліву частину і отримуємо –х,
тобто коефіцієнт стане -1 і вільний
член -3 переносимо до правої частини,
він перетворюється на вільний член 3.
Перший випадок – це лінійне
рівняння з коефіцієнтом -1; 1 та 3.
Друге рівняння.
Друге рівняння відповідає тому,
яке ми задавали вам нещодавно.
Це х-3 = 0.
Ми можемо додати до лівої частини
0у, а -3 перенести до правої частини.
І тоді воно перетвориться також на
лінійне рівняння з двома змінними
з коефіцієнтами перед
змінними 1:0 та вільним членом 3.
Третє рівняння.
Так само як і з
коефіцієнтами перед змінними
у нас і вільний член може дорівнювати 0.
Х = у – це також лінійне
рівняння з двома змінними.
Якщо ми перенесемо у до лівої частини
– отримаємо х + (-у) = 0,
або х - у = 0,
і коефіцієнти перед х та у будуть 1
та -1, та вільний член дорівнюватиме 0.
Четверте рівняння: 0 = 2.
Як це не дивно, хоч ця
рівність і не є правильною,
але це лінійне рівняння з двома змінними.
Воно просто не має
розв`язків. 0х + 0у = 2.
Переходимо до розв`язання
деяких прикладів.
Тож приклад один.
Виразіть з даного рівняння
змінну х через змінну у
і знайдіть який-небудь
розв’язок цього рівняння.
Перший приклад х – 3у = 2.
Тут виразити можна доволі легко,
перемістивши 3у до правої частини,
отримаємо х = 3у + 2.
Якщо замість у підставити 0 в дане
рівняння, то ми легко знаходимо х.
Це буде 2.
Розв`язок цього рівняння
ви бачите на дошці.
Другий приклад: 2х – 4у = 6
Переносимо 4у до правої частини.
Що ми отримаємо в правій частині? 4у + 6.
Перед х у нас зараз стоїть коефіцієнт 2.
Для того, щоб від нього позбутись,
ми використовуємо
властивості звичайних рівнянь,
які ми вчили у програмі 6 класу,.
Вони розповсюджуються
на рівняння з двома змінними
Тобто можна ліву і праву частину ділити на
одне і те саме число (за винятком нуля).
Тому 2х = 4у + 6. Звідси,
х дорівнюватиме 2у + 3.
І аналогічним чином підставивши
замість у довільне число,
ми можемо знайти
розв`язок цього рівняння.
Наприклад, підставивши 2.
2 х 2 = 4, і додати 3 буде дорівнювати 7.
Розв`язок цього рівняння
ви бачите на дошці.
Третій приклад: -6х +у = 7
Переносимо у до правої
частини. Права частина буде 7-у.
І знову, використовуючи
властивості рівнянь,
можемо поділити ліву
і праву частину на -6.
Отримаємо таке
рівняння: х = (7-у)/(-6)
і якщо підставити замість
у 1, то отримаємо х = (-1).
Розв`язок цього рівняння
ви бачите на дошці.
Приклад №2.
При якому значенні параметра a пара чисел
(2a, 3a) є розв’язком рівняння 3x=9-y?
Умова на дошці.
Отже, пара чисел 2а та
3а мають бути розв`язком.
Розв`язок – це коли ми підставляємо
замість відповідної змінної значення,
то ми маємо отримати правильну рівність:
яким змінам відповідають які значення.
Вочевидь х відповідає значення
2а; та у відповідає значення 3а.
Підставляємо їх у рівняння, отримуємо
рівняння відносно однієї змінної,
яке легко розв`язне.
6а = 9 – 3а. До лівої частини
рівняння переносимо –3а
і отримуємо в лівій частині
6а + 3а, тобто 9а.
9а = 9. Звідси легко
знаходиться відповідь а = 1.
Розв`язок цього рівняння
ви бачите на дошці.
Приклад №3.
Умови рівняння ви бачите на дошці.
Що таке протилежні числа?
Це числа однакові за
значенням, але різні за знаком.
Наприклад 5 і -5; 3 і -3.
Прохання не плутати з оберненими
3 і 1/3 – вони не є протилежними.
Якщо у нас рівняння, його
розв`язком є протилежні числа –
це означає, що ми можемо
позначити їх як у; -у, х; -х,
тобто одне з чисел у парі
дорівнюватиме іншій зі знаком мінус.
Підставляючи замість у відповідно -х,
отримаємо знов легке
рівняння відносно однієї змінної.
Тож 7х-х = 6х і поділивши на 6
обидві частини рівняння отримаємо,
що х = 3.
Знаючи, що у має бути протилежним числом,
отримаємо відповідь
до даного рівняння: 3; -3.
Відповідь ви бачите на дошці.
Ця пара чисел є протилежними один до
одного та є розв’язком даного рівняння.
Пропоную розв`язати Вам домашнє завдання.
Завдання ви бачите на дошці.
Відповіді очікуйте в коментарях
під цим відео у мережі YouTube.
А я вже чую як лунає дзвоник. Дякую!